fail ow is a strategic homeland division
agent and was activated after the dollar
flu outbreak as part of the second wave
of agents their task saving what
remained of New York City she's a highly
motivated individual competed of almost
to a fault and exceptionally driven
especially in a devotion to the
rehabilitation and rebuilding of society
in the devastated city so after all
these months or even years depending on
how you'd like to look at it
what catalyst would cause New York's
number one agent to abruptly switch
sites agaric
[Music]
[Music]
you
fail ow is a second-generation
chinese-american when she was only 17
years old tragically she lost both
appearance in a car accident resulting
in her being tasked with raising a
younger sister Heather on her own
records indicate the immense trauma
triggered from this event had
significant impact on which has led to a
number of attachment and intimacy issues
however in turn this enhanced certain
behavioral traits including integrity
accountability empathy resilience vision
and influence resulting in an excellence
in leadership that helped the sister in
the years to come the stood however come
at the expense of her ability to gain
and manage personal relationships while
attending City College they joined the
school's Reserve Officers Training Corps
to use this to help further progress her
career after a number of positions
within military intelligence fails
eventually admitted into the National
Security Agency where she worked as part
of the support staff for the Director of
National Intelligence after the
presidential directive 51 was signed
they relocated to the newly formed
strategic homeland division as a senior
field officer she would be reporting
directly to the northeast section
division commander Lewis Chang
shortly after the first wave of division
agents disappeared President Waller
activated a second wave of agents into
New York City and ordered commander
Chang to personally lead the operations
Fay was activated to serve as Chang's
second-in-command and more importantly
the senior field officer but as the
helicopter was approaching its
destination to pick up Fay in the
remaining agents of the secret wave it
was shot down and destroyed killing
commander Chang and seriously wounding
fate her injuries meant that she had to
be removed from field work but as Fela
was now the most senior agent of the
city she continued to serve as the
acting division commander working from
the New York City base of operations
located in sight James Farley post
office from here she was the primary
contact and strategic support for all
remaining second play of division agents
in New York months pass the division
have made vast steps and regaining
control of New York
all the major hostile faction leaders
have been killed and a number of parts
of the city were started to rebuild
furthermore Intel suggests that the
first wave of rogue agents have left the
city along with their leader Aaron Tina
sometimes I can't believe you're my
sister what are you two after everything
that happened with the first wave how
can you still think the division is the
answer you don't burn down the
institution cuz one employee goes rogue
it wasn't one you know me I don't quit
well you don't have to quit you can keep
doing your mission I'm just saying maybe
it shouldn't be as a division agent it
should be a stay I can't protect you on
my own you got Rhodes Benitez and candle
you're not on your own their support I
don't have the resources we need yeah
well resources aren't everything's a
feather let me know if you still think
that when you run out of food and I'll
keep doing what I have to to make sure
that doesn't happen
knowing there's still a lot of work to
be done bailout makes the choice to stay
in New York along with your sister to
ensure everything continues to run
smoothly while some of the other agents
started working outwards into the
neighboring populations unfortunately
the car wouldn't last long as storm was
coming
if there's water in front they can't be
brave
[Music]
[Music]
this is a distress code the coordinates
for Washington DC
house is possible
someone has to say we can't just leave--
these people
whatever happened it needs to be fixed
or it's all like you go
I'll do what I can here go
[Music]
you
you've got good news Fay afraid not
networks still down we're losing people
out there we need to get you guys back
to full strength again there's an active
protocol we're some agents from all over
the country today see we're doing
everything we can
isn't there anything we can do here to
help to speed things up if we could we
would have done it already
whoever attacked the network knew what
they were doing I hit it right in the
nerve center so that's it then the
division is done we're never done Roy we
adapt and overcome we find solutions in
the face of adversity call the others
it's time to talk strategy
the divisions network was taken down
however protocol dictated that all
available agents must heed to Washington
DC and this meant that divisions
presence in New York was about to take a
drastic dive and surprisingly the JTF
are still in a severely weakened state
which would allow the remaining hostile
presence in the area to rebuild their
ranks and start reclaiming territory
they stayed in New York to do what she
could to stop this from happening
more months pass there is an attack on
the South Manhattan jetty of L post at
City Hall agents from DC are sent to
investigate they learned that the attack
was orchestrated by the rogue agent Erin
keener acting commander of the division
New York agent fellow is the one leading
the manhunt for kina after months of
being the only agent on site this has
seen this division branch devastated
also partially due to a large hurricane
but also the increased hostile presence
the Rikers and cleaners both have new
leaders who are rogue agents from the
first wave it has now been over eight
months since the majority of the
division agents headed to DC and Faiers
finally recovered from her injuries
regrettably a lot has happened over the
last eight months faith in the
government and jtf has been lost and
members are resigning to join the
settlements that are rebuilding
throughout the different districts of
the city we can't keep going like this
we need more guards we don't really have
any other options we can recruit more
people from where the Reich is the
settlement high school we can align
ourselves with another settlement Haven
after everything has happened I don't
think you and Paul trying to work
together again it's such a great idea
Rhodes and I can work it out he's not
completely unreasonable
no he's perfectly reasonable but too
many of your agents have gone rogue I
don't blame them for that trust in the
division you act like we're the problem
like were the cancer and not the
medicine trying to fight it say
sometimes it's the treatment that kills
you
the city has lost faith in the division
time and time again they've seen once
loyal agents of the sh d turn their back
and go rogue even pool roads has had
enough he's resigned from his position
at the base of operations and joined
with the South Manhattan settlement
Haven and along with a number of former
members who else was coming
what do you mean between the settlement
in Hell's Kitchen district has been
attacked by ruckus with near - no
defensive systems and a dwindling amount
of jtf to properly guard in patrol the
facilities there were massive casualties
including face sister while the JTF
waited for backup they rushed ahead and
was one of the first on site there she
managed to capture a wrecker and
interrogated him on what it happened
idiots tried to start a fight over it
none are folded into the way it did you
killed my sister
oh yeah don't remember guess I musta
shot her in the back god damn you
Faye is obviously beside herself a
complete contrast to a usual calm and
collected nature
she puts the sole blame directly onto
the JTF and the fact that they don't
have the numbers to protect the people
entrusted into their care nevertheless
with the help of the division agents
from DC she continues the hunt for Erin
keener
[Music]
and now this is where things start to
get interesting
sometime after the events they had
Heather Lao killed feign manages to
capture a rogue agent who just happens
to be working for the black tusk I know
you're working with someone careful hey
you don't want to make Isaac upset hey
hit me like that again he'll think
you've gone rogue you teamed up with the
JTF we do what we have to you got a
concussion you're the one who isn't
thinking straight what's your mission
agent to save what remains to assure
survival that we live on that when we
finally get back on our feet there is
something left to stand on
cool story fee and how's that working
out for you it's hard
well we're stable sure for now what
about next week for the week after
when you haven't had a Sarah delivery
for months and the medicine runs out and
the people who work together so well
right now turn on one another what are
you gonna do then say we will adapt we
will work together and find a way to
move forward and when they steal your
tech and turn your turrets against you
what will you do then face what I have
to Alicia I'm doing the same you're not
there yet
but you'll see we're the same I'm not
like you I'm not a traitor I'm not a
traitor
I'm effective I can see where this is
going and who can actually make a change
you'll figure it out eventually or
you'll die either way my boys will find
me soon enough and then you'll need to
make a choice what choice is bad to let
me go or see if you're good enough to
take on my team
who are you working with still haven't
figured it out thought you were better
than this
I just want to confirm it you scared
never
you should be we took out the LMB I'm
not afraid of black tusk so you are as
smart as you pretend to be I'm a lot of
things you shouldn't underestimate me
now tell me about your first meeting
with Shafer
how do you know about Shafer it should
really come as no surprise that fate
already knows of Shafer it's more than
likely she's already been approached by
him much like a lot of the other agents
as you might remember listening to the
echo of the black tusk trying to bring
agent OD Cecilia on board highly
intrigued and also wanting more
information fake contacts bard and
chauffeur to offer a trade I need a
trade what kind of trade agent well
information I'm sick of the rumor mill
[ __ ] I know Alicia she was a good
agent she was a good person she
dedicated her life to teaching kids and
now she works for you
what the hell did you do to her we
didn't do anything to her I made her an
offer and she took it
what kind of offer I told her that
anything she wanted regardless of how
ridiculous we could find a way to get it
for that our resources were vast and
wide that the people we work with are
legitimate and are working toward
rebuilding what is broken who do you
work with that information is not for
sale that's what you're asking that I'm
afraid our negotiations are over it was
nice talking to you Lau fair enough need
to know and tell me something else and
Alisha is yours
go ahead how are you getting supplies in
and out of the city
but before faith freed the rogue agent
Elisha cause Walt
she had one last conversation with her
Elisha expresses to Faye that just
because she's gone rogue does not mean
that she isn't still doing a job as a
division agent it's more that the fault
lies in Isaac and whoever programmed it
they way she confides that a goal of
saving what remains of humanity is still
true you're a good agent I'm a great
agent
your rogue you betrayed the division
just because my watch is red it doesn't
mean I've gone rogue that's exactly what
it means no it means that Isaac is not
as smart as his programmer thought he
was you're working with black tusk so
are a lot of people black tusk isn't the
problem being a good little foot soldier
and ignoring what has to be done is the
problem you're off mission Elisha no Hey
you're the one who's off mission we were
recruited because we're adaptable we can
problem solve and have critical thinking
skills we are supposed to be autonomous
we're supposed to think for ourselves
and find solutions to complex problems
with limited resources and part of
finding solutions is recognizing what
can be exploited and deciding whether
the risk is worth the reward you've
already lost everything faith why are
you still holding on to this childish
notion that being loyal to the division
is still the right thing to do
Schaeffer D reading fallback Keener's
dead but he's activated the network
what's the damage
Purnell's watches collating the data
looks like it's all of them no it's
perfect
this will bring the division to its
knees and that's when we'll end them
once and for all
popular opinion seems to be that fate
went rogue because of his sister's death
and that she blames the JTF and
government for it due to their lack of
resources and manpower that was needed
to properly maintain what little order
they were able to achieve in New York
though she was obviously affected by a
sister's death I think it's more that
the situation opened her eyes so to
speak and made her more susceptible to
suggestion
enabling her to listen to Alesha cos
Walt's reasoning behind going rogue and
aligning with the black tusk Fela was a
patriot and is fully devoted to the
cause of restoring order but now she
doesn't believe that the people calling
the shots behind the strategic homeland
division are the ones that have the
people's best interest at heart sound
familiar
I'm gonna go into a lot more detail on
this and a video coming up but what do
you think did fail outbreak character
and lose all sense of reality and what
is truly right because her sister was
killed whereas she too joined the black
tusk along with the other rogue agents
for the good of the people thank you
very much for watching I hope you've
enjoyed this if you're looking for yet
another place to geek out on this sort
of stuff or maybe just to reminisce on
how much you miss being able to go
outside
she got me discord we have great little
community building up here you'll find
me on there pretty much every day lately
has I'm stuck at home like everyone else
you know I'll catch in the neck
tears
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]